we just saw the opening sequence which
was amazing yeah and once again
did you enjoy that's what we like to
hear
once again you're holding your breath
now is this just something you kind of
like do I think Matthew Vaughn just
likes to see me struggle basic and oh
you literally do you have to hold you
better along or you can be aid so you
kind of you sit in the car and you get
the seat belt on and then they just sink
you into the water and you go down with
a with a regulator and someone speaking
to you on an underwater speaker and they
go okay teryn we're going to ask you to
take your last five breaths and we'd
like you to remove the regulator you
know meanwhile you're trying to stop
yourself having a heart attack
and it sinks in take the regulator out
and then you're stuck under there and
you're strapped in and if something goes
horribly wrong I mean thankfully nothing
did but it's quite scary you bolt up
since the bus in a good way you know
you're you're you have a he has a deeper
chest on him I can see from my vantage
point that much very much that must be
all the breath holding you've been yeah
they might have underwater work I've
done that being said I am nothing in
terms of strength compared to one mr.
Channing Tatum hold on oh hang on Magic
Mike hang on here is where's it by
himself
uh I all I will say is don't get in a
fight with Channing Tatum well some of
us might enjoy the experience and so
pretty good Channing maybe I should lead
to you here sorry the jump over you here
calling but you can see there's a
bromance going on okay
were you were you as impressed by
talyn's physical presence strength
ability and masculinity as he clearly is
overawed by yours
no no no how's it look he's unbelievably
talented maybe not in the strength area
ah no no he's unbelievable man okay uh
Colleen it's fabulous to see you back it
kind of be a war winner Colleen [ __ ]
that is gentlemen
[Applause]
Colleen I'm kind of surprised I love the
first my mom's a bit surprised to see
you back here in the in the second film
on stage
what were you surprised when you got the
call or did you know that maybe you were
what we call a survivor it's all a
mystery to me
really I mean I I'm in the trailer and I
yeah it seemed to do a lot of Shaving
and that's really all I can say so
maybe you should jump over me again
so you're here but you're not 100 I'm
not here I'm going to jump over you
Channing and come back to me obviously
Hallie
it's great to have Halle Berry with a
steak dinner in here many times many
films that are loved by the crowd here
comic-con
you play ginger who's ginger in the
states burn wood what's your role ginger
her name is really ginger ale
she's a mixer I'm mixed glad I chose me
she is sort of the does what Mark Strong
does for the Kingsmen ginger does for
the Statesmen so she's kind of the
techie brain nerdy character of the of
the Statesmen and she has hidden debts
I'm just going to say that Oh another
kind of hidden depths at town would have
to hold his breath to go into or they uh
I don't know what that meant and I
apologize it sounded slightly old that I
apologize Pedro let's go to Pedro - save
me Pedro hi great to have you here I
love you are you're playing one of these
stereotypical Southern gentlemen that
Jane's inflicted on the world and you
get to use the the Larry at the LA Zoo
the bullwhip I believe did you master
those skills for the movie under prop
sky yeah I was in training with some
cowboy experts and learned how to use
the lasso the last two to lasso right
laughing having this fight in England
for the four months I was
they're shooting this movie and Don
telling me hold on hold on Jeff you're
on authority on all things Western lasso
or lasso we call it a rope deaf which is
boom soy paralyzed you were incorrectly
talking about your rope
are you mass did you use the bullwhip as
well cuz those things and angles as well
yeah that was my favorite bit the whip
how many people out there have cracked a
whip properly yeah it's really fun um
when you make that noise it becomes
quite addictive and um and you can
injure yourself that's for sure I didn't
did you enjoy anyone else what's that
did you enjoy anyone else um no I was
really really good at it I was good at
the whip it was my specialty we are in
the presence of Hollywood royalty Jeff
Bridges ladies and gentleman
unbelievable to have you here jack ah
you're kind of the head of the Statesmen
I guess what's your code name
I'm champagne Wow but I'd like to be
called champ ha ha ha and I notice in
the movie you know you're wanting this
booze business you you don't tend to
drink much with you you're sniffing it
you seem to be sniffing it there's some
spitting in the film involved you spit
some of them out in your spittoon is
there a reason why he doesn't imbibe
yeah well he's kind of challenged by his
vices but he's a tough guy and so he
likes to get right up or in the face of
that vise and you know he put you I
think he wears the booze as a cologne
actually yeah he liked to put it on he
he likes to back oh but doesn't want to
smoke cause you know that's bad for him
but he'd like to sniff that thing you
know you'll suck on it won't light it
but you know he likes to surround
himself with surround himself with what
he's afraid of I got stuck in the
elevator with a guy who smelled like
that last night
it's hard to lose the carrot very good
one of the things I think we all loved
about the first film was their
connection the emotional connection
between Howie and eggsy that was great
and that continues in this one I'm guess
that's one of the reasons why you like
doing it Colin because of my emotional
yeah bond with young talent here yes
that's actually a reason I there's a you
know when you're doing a thing which has
got a lot of this stuff the action and
all the rest of it it doesn't matter how
loud the explosions are or how fast the
cars are going on if you're not rooting
for someone it kind of dries up after a
while
and so you know Matthew is really very
good at bringing that out is you know
you invest something in the characters
and so you know it's got all that so
dynamic stuff but I think there's a
couple of hankerchief moments as well
well we've all met Matthew Vaughn he's
not what we would call an emotional
person I suspect most of that comes from
Jane
I mean Matthew doesn't have emotions I
believe they're not recognizable to the
rest of it you know we should get him
I'm going to see if I'm getting on the
phone would you like to speak to Matthew
briefly here we're going to be we're
here as evidence more okay again one but
first of all why Jeff you didn't did you
get the drink any of the Statesmen
reserved in the movie or did you just
put it behind your ears I took a shot at
- okay and do you recommend it so what
do you recommend it oh yeah yeah good
stuff good stuff because I know I know
it's early here but it's seven o'clock
in England so if you guys want to start
the party I wish
[Music]
I got one I don't know who wants this
glass they gave me that one as well I
don't know some guy will do this great
and I'll get I'll get Matthew Vaughn on
the phone and we can hear from him as
well let's get him on FaceTime so you
can see him as I said he's working hard
in London editing the movie but he
wanted to say hi to you in person
hang on Hallie Hey hey guys I've got
Matthew Vaughn on the line can you get a
camera over here for me
Matthew out your yeah are you editing it
doesn't look like you in an edit suite
to me where's a camera can you gain one
weekend with it getting close on the
phone there that look where are you I
can see a swimming pool in the
background Matthew you're forcing actors
to hold their breath again aren't you
Matthew you got a message back you got a
message for everyone here in Hall H well
it's probably going better than you
being here are you happy is not here
guys no it's all character
Matthew they're drinking heavily we'll
get back to you Matthew Vaughn ladies
gentlemen I think we should maybe all
know you still on the light okay I think
maybe we should go to some questions
from you in the audience if we're ready
to go then as I said we'll give away
Dave's illustration as well so if you're
ready to take questions let's go over to
the first of our questions from the
audience member over there he's coming
up to the microphone now you introduce
yourself and tell us who the questions
for police sir
hi there my name is Sam my questions for
the entire cast I was just wondering if
it was as fun to film this movie as it
looks on screen and if there was any
stories from filming that stand out was
it as fun to film I wasn't really paying
attention what yeah yeah was it it's fun
to film this movie as it looked on
screen because it looks pretty damn fun
so as much fun to film as the finished
product for us to watch absolutely 100%
I mean it's crazy hard work but it's
such a great atmosphere Matthew creates
a spirit of fun and you know it's like
it's a dream job if the movie is so cool
and you know you're working with people
like this every day I mean it you know
you get hurt a little bit as an
occupational hazard I got my hand
slammed in that car door and Edie whole
coffee place Charlie punched me square
in the face which I really didn't a
priest appreciate but yeah it's great
also anyone else have a good time yeah
it was fun look I just come out to it I
was like a fan fan of the first one and
that's I was begging to be in this movie
and so yeah and think other guys were
just a lot of fun I don't give a spoiler
away here we do get to see Channing in a
bowler hat in the film was that your
first time in a British bowler maybe not
no you might I might have really liked
Clockwork Orange
you have your own bowler hat at home
Channing maybe maybe I like to get a
little weird
okay just for those special occasions by
kind of bursaries yeah exactly
oh gosh what okay thank you a question
sir thank you let's have our next
question hello I am David I have a
question for Halle Berry which movie do
you think is more British James Bond or
this one oh yeah Halle you've been in
the bar that's not fair oh oh I get a
pass
I'm packed enough to call it can she
drink in bed why Martin they have that
much Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck I
can't now I'll bet you see that
[Applause]
[Applause]
Kingsman and fox bones would like to
remind you to drink responsibly not like
Halle Berry okay she's our professional
she can handle it okay thank you for
your question sir thank you
next question please you're welcome
what's up guys it's the first time
meeting your challenge and you're one my
favorites especially you Haughey
and nice job for drinking nice job on
drinking the clock class I was a my
granny what was
oh she's drunk all right adored someone
question yes oh good
my question is pertaining one of the
most memorable scene you'll never forget
about Kingsman most memorable scene for
you Channing in this movie
um I can't tell you this is the most
memorable scene in this movie nice try
though Channing's boil the movie for
everybody all of them they're amazing
[Laughter]
anyone with Halle Berry okay
okay they're all memorable they're all
memorable every scene is amazing let's
have another question please hi I'm
Jonah and my question was I'm what's the
main difference between getting ready
for the first Kingsman versus getting
ready for the sequel
okay we'll have to give that to Colin in
town here uh I don't think it was a
great deal of different socially it was
pretty much the same same hours and
hours and hours of choreography and
waiting holding breath holding and
getting punched and being thrown at a
wall and I mean I loved it don't get me
wrong but nice when it wraps to probably
without giving much why you you're in a
very different your character in a very
different place in this film and me yes
I mean I'm just sitting here thinking
what on earth can I possibly say because
to make the tiniest reference to
anything I do
feels like a spoiler but Jonathan's
right I had a bit of a different task
this time and different things to
prepare as probably about as clear as I
can be there was nothing like the
training into the first film was immense
for someone who has absolutely no
athletic history whatsoever to be told
that I didn't have to do very much but
killed 200 people in a church and pain
world was involved with me as well I had
some minor ly life-changing injuries
yeah minor a scratch and it's got a Jane
Chris change the other surviving member
from Kingsman one what was it the
challenges facing you in making the
sequel as good if not better than the
first I think in a way it's great
knowing that people there are good
people people watching it who know what
to expect that was a fair with the first
one it's such an out-there movie so it's
actually lovely knowing that there's an
audience who kind of know what Kingsman
is and I'm going to welcome what's to
come and I guess it's hard coming up
with a villain as good as the first one
because Sam Jackson was amazing in the
first film called where did you go to
for the villain and what was your
intention in this second movie I think
Matthew and I have always agreed that
the important thing about villain is
that they actually their ethos and what
they want should be something that
actually you debate afterwards with your
friends and say you know what they had a
point it's just the way they went about
it was wrong
and I think in the villain in this movie
I think we're gonna we're going to show
a clip Michelle kept in a few minutes
here amazing yeah I think I mean we were
incredibly fortunate to get Julianne
Moore and her character poppy I think
people will not be disappointed here
more another Academy Award winner in
Kings went to let's have another
question thank you sir thank you Jonah
hi my name is Mike this question is for
Jeff Bridges if the dude was a statement
as a statesman how would he feel about
be
his statesman the dude would probably
number one he probably wouldn't make
bourbon
he'd make that clear stuff you know
vodka play Russian uh White Russian you
say no I mean I think you know I
probably go deep inside myself and
really think about uh what what Jeff
like I don't like I like my Russians
clear transparent he probably moved in
very proudly yeah
David who like okay let's have one more
question we have one more question and
then we'll pick a winner for this game
Colin guys my name is Tommy hey Hallie
anytime you want to drink like that girl
boys you go and it happened once in my
life never yet my question is what
quality is in a person to make them a
true Kingsman in your guys's opinion for
the whole cast or statesman I guess the
King's nice legs yeah well what quality
do you need what's required now and
let's go to you first
okay sorry yeah item momentary lapse you
know it's doing everything about it um
but I'm back in the room yes okay in
terms of what it takes to be a Kingsman
I think are impeccable manners right
manners maketh man as we know
I suspect probably the ability to throw
a pretty decent right hook as well and
of course you know some seriously
beautiful threads as well yeah yeah
immaculate Colleen
yeah I'd second all that I think your
umbrella work needs to be pretty good
yeah it's all I'd really I'd really add
to that and also identify supply to the
Statesmen but good emotional management
Channing for a statesman um gotta be a
drink and fight first yeah that's I
don't know know about I don't know about
anything else
Holly I'm for a statesman woman you have
to be able to put down a pint of bourbon
and still fan and don't make get your
hair messed up why are you doing it you
know every panel you on the future they
can all shoot it down a whole pint of
whiskey this is neut red head rope just
crack that whip yeah and Jeff nice pair
of boots comes in handy
you're booted father okay so you know I
said early on we're going to do
something with your t-shirts on well the
time is now ladies and gentlemen we're
going to do a group shot with everyone
in the hall standing up in their
Kingsland t-shirt you are officially a
Kingsman or if you like a statesman
after this because you'll know this is
the jacket that eggsy wears when he has
a special occasion and we have that here
as well we'll bring that out but if you
stand up let's get like some guys would
you come over here we're going to do a
selfie with everyone in the background
talans got his special Kingsman Jackie
which Matty job he's both taught
tailoring from Kingsman okay okay don't
fall off the stage someone hold on a
Hallie she's had a few okay
if you can get behind why okay
gathering okay okay everyone behind ya
we're getting a good crowd
okay and how do you okay that's pretty
good that's pretty good
oh I've got a mic that's what's earrings
okay we're going to put those online had
a lot give um find yourself in the
photograph given out and Wow and Talon
is modeling that King's when Jackie
count on give us a walk up here let's
see how they see this kingdom over there
that's pretty good okay
[Applause]
you